here we are in the dojo
it's very peaceful
I can hear the clock ticking
but apart from there
the air is still
I'm going to
talk you through what I do as a
meditation
and
it sounds different but my
trying to
sit and just wait
I close my eyes
so
imagine yourself
go into the store
place in yourself
on the Storm
if you need to just go forward on your
knees
lift the stone lamp place your legs
through the middle
of the Stone
so your feet are coming
to get them out of the bag
and you'll slowly now going down onto
the stone
and try to find a comfortable place in
your mind
imagine that you are sitting there
because for the next
few moments
you will be there
in the dojo
and it will be your own space
and then part of the microwave it would
be your space underneath
with an outward breath slowly close your
eyes
with your eyes closed
how does your breath fail
trying not to add to it
just allow it to be itself
and the calmer you become
the calm and the breath will become
the mind is always active and always
trying to give us
information so that we cannot stay in
peace
so with your eyes closed
and your breath doing its own thing
imagine that you have another pair of
your own eyes
looking at you sitting on the stove
so as if you're going to transform
yourself
to be yourself outside of the body
that's sitting on the Storm
and I'd like you to
find the position in the room here
and immensely Place yourself
somewhere hovering above where you are
now
and slowly as if you're on the floating
piece of air just taking you around the
room
looking at yourself
sitting in there
go to bed and Rush
take your time
if you find any part difficult
just pause
wait
in the position you are
until you can move on again until you're
back
to the place that you started
don't worry if you're on your first few
tries
you find this impossible to do
the first step is to see yourself
outside yourself
you may be in different clothing outside
yourself
than where you are sitting on the stove
don't let this trouble you
just accept that your mind is wanting to
play tricks on you
it wants you to work hard and worry
about it
but we're here not to worry
but we're here to find calmness
grounding
and depth
when you're ready and there is no rush
and if you're happy staying there
just calmly in a nice sit position a
nice situation
you're inside the dojo
you'll come on
you're going to slowly open your eyes
but not fully when you're ready and
you're going to be looking and
concentrating
on the house
of course you can see everything else
around you
everything on this Farm
but except that it's all there
but your consultation is from the
Showman
I'd like you to start at the bottom of
the first step of the house
they really are going to be staying on
the Storm
I want you to fail inside your chest
as you step one step at a time
that would be in a rush
feel the step firmly with inside you
then calm yourself
when you're ready and only when you're
ready
go to the next step
calm yourself
sometimes a step will be easy
sometimes it will leave your chest heavy
again don't worry about this
it's all the tricks of the Mind
bothering you
are you calm or are you getting some
tension
if you're getting some tension it just
means you're nervous
you don't know how to let go
it's the mind playing with you
of course you shouldn't be nervous
here you are in a calm state
at any given time going up these steps
if you wish to close your eyes
just to calm yourself again
the breaths may be a little bit deeper
than what they were before you started
the steps
try not to help them
just watch the breaths
and don't open your eyes again until the
breaths become calm
before they become calm
perhaps open them but they're not as
wide as they were before
and continue until you make the top of
the steps
how bright
is the silver disc shining into your
eyes
is the blindness really powerful
don't question how powerful there is
towards you as if there's anything wrong
it is to ward off evil spirits
but because you have become so close to
the Gods that reside in the house
is just showing you how powerful they
are and how powerful the defense has
been
so slowly turn yourself around and you
can see yourself in miniature
if this helps
walk down the stacks
fill each step on the edge but as you
take these steps
until you receive the bottom which
when you receive the bottom step
and the feeling that it gives you slowly
close your eyes again
draw yourself from the steps inside
yourself
take your breath
if it's calm
that's good if it's not calm wait until
it becomes calm
comes come
open your eyes when you're ready
they're going to climatize yourself to
the room
and this is the end of the first
meditation
of this series
you must get on
or do whatever you wish in your mental
part of your mind
you might want to walk around this dojo
or you may just go back to being in
yourself wherever you are in the world
but know that you've found the calmness
of just sitting
and observing
thank you for your time